Okay. So guys, welcome to the call. It is October 22nd, 2024. We're almost a month into
Q4, which is going to put us at like, you know, we have like two to less than two and
a half months, like 10 weeks left in the year, probably less than 10 weeks left in the year.
And it's just crazy how these years are flying by these months are flying by. But anyway,
I just saw the date really quick. Couple things real, real quick. Number one, I hope you guys
are having as much fun and as excited about this new RankinRent engine tool as I am. I'm
not in there every single day. I don't want to lie to you, but I am doing this multiple
times a week. I'm, you know, blocking out time where I can go in. I can run due diligence.
I can, you know, we've added all of our projects in there. We're testing the search volume
tool. We're looking at our, what's it called? Our project management side. And we're doing
everything inside of RankinRent engine. So if you guys have no idea what I'm talking
about, you probably were not on the live that we ran a couple of weeks ago with Ryan Dalton.
And basically in short, we now have an official tool that we can say definitively, this is
the tool that we're going to use. This is the standard. This is the metrics we're going
to go off of. This is going to be when we say, here's how much it needs to be in search
volume. It's going to go off of this tool. And that is exciting because up until now,
it's kind of been like, hey, use whatever you want. And you have to kind of figure out
the numbers on your own, which is good and bad. But I'm excited because I've never been
able to like endorse any tool or say this is the one because I didn't have control over
it. Right. And so, you know, we've used SEMrush. We've used Mangools. We've used, we've talked
about keyword planner. We've talked about, what else? There's a bunch of different ones
that we've talked about with Ahrefs, like all kinds of different stuff. But now we have
one RankinRentEngine.com and we are in the middle of a four to five week beta test. It
is a paid beta test and we've gotten some really, really good feedback. We know it's
not perfect. We weren't expecting it to be perfect. And that's why we asked you guys
to help us. And so I know for me and my team, we're in there between all of us. We're in
there every single day and we've already done a bunch of, we've given a bunch of feedback
to Ryan who he's taking to the developers and we're making those adjustments. And yeah.
So anyway, if you guys don't know what I'm talking about, you missed that, go to RankinRentEngine.com
what I would actually encourage you to do. And I'm saying this because I had somebody
message me, it was this morning or yesterday that said, hey, so do you recommend that I
use SEMrush? And I said, no, that's not the case at all. I recommend that you use RankinRentEngine.
And so I want to drop this live that we did. Let me see if I can find it really quick.
Hold on. Tool Ryan Dalton. Check out this live that I did with Ryan Dalton. And from
this, hold on. Okay. Pause that. From this guys, you can go, what's up Nicholas John,
man. Okay. You guys want to check that out. And if you are somebody that wants to be part
of the paid beta, you can use the following code. I'll drop that in as well. Here we go.
I think it's Ignition24 and it's like a 20% off discount for the first couple of months.
But I am stoked about the tool. Just because it does all the stuff that I was, I had like
all kinds of tools. I had Google Sheets. We had Pipe Drive. We had a custom tool that
our software guy built for us. We were using, at one point using Asana. We were also using,
there's another one. I can't even remember what it's called. I mean, we had like five,
six, seven different tools that we were checking out, trying with Google Drive, this, that,
the rest. Now we have one place. We have our team members. We can assign tasks. We can
keep track. We can see what we need to do. And it's pretty dang cool. You can see your projects.
It saves all your due diligence. If nothing else, the thing that I love the most, guys,
is that it's saving me a ton of time on the due diligence. So anyway, guys,
if you don't know what I'm talking about, then check out that live. Use that code if you're
interested. If not, we're going to be doing an official launch the first or second week
of November, but it is going to be full price. So if you're interested, I would check that out
as soon as possible. Okay. Last two things, guys, really, really quick. I made this post
inside of the art of digital real estate, our free group. And I did that because I didn't want
to confuse anyone. I wanted to wait and explain this to you guys. But guys, if you do not already,
hold on one second. Let me get rid of these stupid notifications. If you do not already,
hold on, hold on. Give me one second.
Okay. If you guys have not already seen that post, me and Francesca and our agency are in the process
of really trying to scale. And we are looking for people who have websites, projects that are
ranking, that are producing leads, but that do not have clients yet. Maybe you guys have built them
and you've tried to get a client. You haven't been able to. They're getting leads, whatever the case
is. And you want to turn those into cash because you now, first and foremost, if you, I encourage
you to keep your assets, right? Because an asset is something that's going to pay you again and
again and again. And if all you need is a renter, I want you to keep trying to get them in. I don't
want you guys to do this, to hook me up. I'm talking about those of you that may have a
website that you've tried to sell it. You can't sell it, whatever the case is, or maybe you need
some quick cash. I want you to message Francesca, let her know. Now this needs to be a website that
is consistently producing leads that does not have a business owner. Okay. It's ranking and
producing leads, not with ads, because guys, I can go set up my own. We have our own projects
running with ads. I'm talking about projects that are already ranking that do not have clients that
you want to potentially turn into cash. And by the way, we are going to make an offer to you. If we
look at it, it looks good. We'll make an offer to you. And we're going to make a fair offer, right?
If you don't have a client, it's not going to be worth near what it's going to be worth with a
client. But I don't want your website as a client because I can go find a client, right? That's what
I do. It's not that difficult. But if you are somebody that has a project that is ranking,
has leads coming in, then message Francesca if you're interested in possibly offloading that.
Okay. Last thing I want to mention, guys, is we are in the process of outlining version 3.0 of our
training. So this will be the third time that we've actually shot the training. We're outlining
right now, looking to shoot it and finalize it in quarter one of next year. So don't get too,
I don't want everyone to ask me every five seconds when it's going to be done.
Where there's a few things that we're testing, there's a few things that we're making sure,
like for example, we are actually trying a new strategy, a new kind of wrinkle to our ads set up
and our ads process, which we are now in the week, probably six of testing. And we're probably going
to be doing it for three, three, four more weeks. That's going to be something that we include in
version 3.0. I'm bringing this up because if you guys have things, feedback, suggestions,
please DM me and fix it Felix on a group message and let us know. But we like, I'm not going to
sit here and pretend like it's perfect. I know it's not perfect. There's things that have changed.
There's things that I'm doing differently that I wasn't doing. We understand that there's a
few things that may be a little bit confusing that we didn't realize. So rather than making like
a post that says, oh, I don't understand this, this and this, just message us and we're going
to add that to the outline. It is okay if you guys ask questions, but we would just appreciate
the feedback and just know that we're working on it. We hear your feedback. We're excited to make
the version 3.0 and there's also going to be a 4.0 and a 5.0 and probably a 10.0 because we're
never going to be done with this business because I'm in this business just like you guys are in
this business. Okay. That said guys, let's go into the call today. Let's talk about taxes. Let's
talk about how to save money. Let's talk about how to keep as much money as possible that we're
actually making. So I want to give you a little context. My buddy, Cale Goodman is going to be
joining me here in about two minutes. Cale is a guy I met back in 2016. Ironically, I met Cale
right when I started my agency, right when I started doing my own ranking, right? And this
is at the point where I was just trying to get clients and I didn't understand what industries
to go into, what a good city looked like, what a good niche looked like. And I was literally in
the process of reaching out to all my buddies. Hey, do you know anybody that owns a business?
Do you know anybody that owns a business? And I got introduced to Cale Goodman. We went and actually
had sushi with another buddy of mine and he owns this amazing company called Easier Accounting.
Now, I didn't realize at the time this probably wasn't the best industry to generate leads doing
the method that we use, the rank and rent method. But you know what? I was out there just making
offers, trying to get money coming in the door. So we met for lunch. He said, hey, come by the office.
I went to the office and I sat in front of him and three of his, sorry, two partners, so three
total people across from me. And I pitched them on this idea of doing rank and rent,
building a website, ranking it and sending them leads. And when I walked out of that meeting,
I walked out with a thousand dollar check and he shook my hand and he put his faith in me,
said, go get me some leads. Now, I didn't do a flat fee deal. I did like a paper lead, whatever.
And to be very honest, I got him a few leads and I knew it wasn't going to work. He knew
it wasn't going to work. He was cool about it. He gave me a chance and I didn't know that that
wasn't the greatest. Now, funny enough, I actually generated leads. I had a website called like
reddesertaccounting.com, something like that. And leads actually came in. The issue was they
weren't the type of leads that he was looking for because he has a very specific type of person
he wants to work with and that he does the best with. And so it wasn't the best use of
the rank and rent model. However, that's the first thing. A couple of years later, that was 2016,
2017 guys, or sorry, end of 2016. Many of you guys know I went and tried to start a software company.
I thought I was too cool for school. I thought I was too cool for the rank and rent model. I
went and tried to start a software company, which I failed miserably at. After that was done,
end of 2017, July, end of July, I started getting into SEO. I needed to pay the bills. I needed to
pay the bills. I was trying to get money coming in and I needed SEO money because I needed as
much as possible. I needed to keep, you know, those high margin deals. Well, a few months after,
maybe six months after I got really heavy into that SEO, you know, aspect pitching deals and
everything, I had a guy that I was partnering with on this SEO stuff. And I said to him, I said,
hey, I know these guys, let's go meet with them. It's going to be tough. You know, the SEO in this
space is difficult. And there we were, what is a year and a half later, sitting at the same table,
this time pitching an SEO deal. And I will be, I'm happy to tell you guys, I walked out of that deal
with a $4,000 per month retainer doing their SEO. And we did that for about six months, I believe.
And then this guy, Cale called me and he's like, dude, I'm doing the math here. I'm thinking I'm
just hiring somebody because I'm paying you guys like 4,000 bucks a month. So he's like, I just
want to let you know, you guys have been great. Said, no problem, man. I totally get it. Obviously,
it killed me to hear that, but I was like, whatever. And funny enough, he ended up taking my
partner. My partner called me. He's like, dude, I need something that's very, that's like more stable.
He's like, I think I'm going to apply for this job. So they ended up basically pulling him out
of my hand and hiring him for that retainer plus a little bit of money. And that was it.
We've maintained a great relationship over the years and he's just a super cool dude. I'm excited
for you guys to actually get to know him, get some tips, get some tips and tricks, some strategies
from him. And I want to say one thing. What I've learned about accounting is this can either make
you or break you. I was sitting with a guy that's worth over a hundred million dollars and he said
to me repeatedly, he said, it's not about what you make. It's about what you can keep. The second
thing my dad always, something my dad always used to tell me is he said, there's two things that you
do not want to be cheap about. And this is somebody taught him this. It's your attorney
and it's your accountant because you never want to scrimp on that. And so guys, from the day that I
started making money on my own, I've been paying professionals. I've never tried to do attorney
work on my own. I've always paid someone to start a set up my businesses, whatever. And I've always
paid an accountant to keep my books. I've spent, you know, heaven knows how much money on it, but
I know I've made five, 10 X what I've spent. So I'm excited. I'm going to be Kaelin right now.
And guys, the very last thing I'll say, if I heard somebody say this a few years back and it really
resonated with me, if you want to make professional money, you need to treat this business professionally.
The reason some of you guys are making side hustle money is because you're treating this
like a side hustle. The reason I make professional money doing this is because I treat this
professionally. I don't mess around with this. This is my business. This is my baby. I don't,
I'm not freaking doing this for my mom's basement. And even if I was, I'm treating this as if I'm
sitting at a skyscraper in a corner office. If you want to make professional money,
treat this professionally. And this is a way that you can do that. So let me bring Kaelin
really quick and we will get right into this call. One second. Let me see where he's at.
Hold on. There we go.
All right. Let's see if these guys can hear me. Kael, let me know if you can hear me, bro.
Got double Kael. I think it's Kason coming on with him.
Hold on. One sec. Oh, there he is. What's up, bro?
Dude, we're trying out something new today. We got the, like, the vibe board up over here
so we can share some stuff with you guys over there. We got super cool stuff for everybody
today and we're excited to be here. Amazing. Kason, what's up, bro? How are you?
I'm good, dude. Are you guys trying to join from another link as well? It says something's
connecting the audio. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, okay. Cool. I'll grab it. Yeah. No, no, no. You're good. You're
good. I just want to make sure there wasn't somebody else. So, Kael, what's up, bro? How
you doing? I'm doing great, man. Thanks for having me on today. For sure, man. I'm stoked
about this. I was just kind of giving a little preface introduction and told everyone that when
I first started doing this business, I came in and I was pitching you and I think it was JD
and Trevor. And yeah, you had faith in me. You gave me a chance, which I appreciated. And then
we did an SEO deal together and you stole my partner, Corey, which is cool.
That was cool. By the way, you just muted yourself on accident. Hold on.
Yeah, just unmute yourself. Okay. There you go. I can hear you now. You're good. You're good.
Okay. Oh, you have that one. Okay. So yeah, just me, one of them. And let me know. You can hear me,
right? No, we're good. We can hear you just fine. Do you hear an echo? Yeah, I'm here to echo.
You're good. You're good. Take care of it. And then we'll go through. So guys, real quick,
while they're getting that stuff set up, I want you guys, if you have questions related to taxes
and accounting related to this business, you guys can start dropping them in the comments.
We'll hit those at the end. Kael, you still got me? Oh, shit. I can't hear you now, bro.
Dude. There we go. I could see myself twice. I can see myself on the, but I can't hear an
echo anymore. So I think we're good there. Beautiful. Can you hear me? Yeah, we're good,
but no echo. So we're good. Sweet, dude. So yeah, that's dope, dude. So let's start off by just
doing like an intro, how the hell you got here into this space. Then I know you guys got some
stuff you want to share. I've also got some things that are interesting for me to kind of just throw
out there, but yeah, let's just kind of, let's start rolling. All of it, man. So to give you a
little background. Well, first of all, uh, me and Nick, you know, we, we talked for, I don't know,
dude months at the gym. That's where I first met you is at the gym. And then you were kind of like,
dude, I want to come in and show you some stuff. Right. And then he built a kind of a competing
company that did generate us leads. What wasn't it? It was just a competing company on our,
on a Google. Anyway, the whole thing worked is all I was going to say. And so it's kind of cool
to see years later, how you spun this up. You're teaching other people how to do it. You're getting
people results. And I really like it because it's a business model where people can get out and they
can make money. Anybody's got a little hustle to them and anyone's got like, you know, some,
some charisma about them. Like they can get out and find these deals all day long with people,
you know? And so, um, so I really like it because you can instantly be what they call open for
business, which is a tax term. I want to talk about with these guys today as well, which is huge to
open up a ton of tax savings, no matter what happens with business. And so, um, so that's kind
of a really cool thing that I like about your business model as well as like, literally you
can get people instantly open for business by IRS terms to help them really keep a ton of money in
the building phases. And so, uh, but, uh, but to give a little background, dude, so I, um, I,
so I actually came from a household growing up where all we did was fight about money in our
house, right? My parents were like constantly battling because my dad was a self-employed
blue collar contractor, he did siding, rain gutters, you know, solve a patient. He's just a,
just a contractor guy, but he was an independent guy. He had a crew, um, and he never understood
the money side of business and he never wanted to prioritize it. Um, so all I heard about my entire
household, my whole, my whole upbringing was, you know, this fight about the IRS, right? And so my
mom, uh, and dad were constantly fighting about money. And eventually after years and years and
years of them always fighting about this IRS, I didn't know what it was. I'm just a kid, right?
But as I got older, I started understanding more. And then the IRS finally, after a while, they
came in and started taking things, right? So, um, they, they literally came in and leaned my dad's
house. Um, they levy did his bank account. So I remember I helped him finish a job up in Salt Lake
City. Um, just as a young kid, I think I was like 13 or something working on a big apartment complex
up there with him. He was so excited to come put this big check in the bank, pay all his guys,
pay some money to the IRS because they'd been on his back before the second he put that money in
the bank account before he could use any of it. Boom, levy took it all out. He's like some $40,000
check, you know? And so now they're levy his bank accounts. They're leaning his home. My mom goes
and gets a job as a grocery, you know, a checker at Albertsons here in town. And they end up
garnishing your paychecks after like a month or two of working there. And so now, now they just
really squoze my parents to where like literally my dad had to just work for cash under the table,
you know? So in my mind, I was like, why would anybody want to be a business owner? I don't
ever want to do that. Like, heck no. And so, um, but I always wanted to make money. I always want
to have a great, great life. I always wanted to have financial abundance. And so, you know,
and I was just a hustler at heart. And so, uh, one of the best things that ever happened to me
is I ended up getting recruited as a sales guy by a guy that owned a tax and accounting firm to come
and do business development and sales with his entire, uh, accounting company. And so I got
really good at that. I became his top guy. I really, because of my upbringing, really threw
myself into it. And so I spent more time with the CPAs than I did the other sales guys, constantly
just trying to learn as much as I possibly could, because I finally understood like, wow, the IRS
didn't take everything from us. My dad just didn't understand it. He didn't want to put the
effort into getting the knowledge and creating the systems and the habits around the money side of
business, the tax side of business in order to really become successful. And so that gave me the
courage to start my own business. And then it gave me the courage to start my own accounting firm
and partner with some really great CPAs. And so here we are over 15 years later, and we've got
an awesome accounting firm. We got multiple CPAs and EAs and accountants with masters
that are in here serving our clients. And so our whole thing is like, Hey, we want to serve
business owners the way they need to be served, right? Cause anybody can do it. My dad did where
they went down, they just had a CPA and they brought them all their stuff every year and they
guessed. And then they, and then they, the accountants really just doing what the business
owner brings them. And then they ended up getting behind the IRS and now they're overwhelmed by it.
So they ignore it and all these problems just, you know, start to compound, you know? And so
that's basically what we try to avoid. And so even though our company has evolved and we've got
companies that are 20, 30, 40, 50 million dollar companies that we do high level tax planning for,
I have always stayed very passionate about helping people kind of in that startup mode. And they're,
they're really just, you know, doing their first side hustle or they're, they're just throwing
themselves into their first business. Cause I know that all the magic happens by helping them build
the foundation correctly in the beginning stages. Because what I've seen, even with successful
business owners is five, six, seven years in, they realize like, holy crap, man, I made
a ton of mistakes. I didn't know I shouldn't have brought in a partner and we did an S corp together.
I didn't know I should have, you know, had an LLC and just stayed a partnership there and then
created an S corp later individually. I didn't know C corporations were a thing and that there's
tax advantages to that once I hit certain levels and I have certain goals. And so, you know, and
then what happens is they have to redo it. And so, and that's what, that's what we like to do is
like really help entrepreneurs, like get the information they need, inspire them to start
creating the right habits, tax wise, get the right foundation laid, you know, and, and that way as
they scale, you know, cause everybody wants to scale, everybody wants to become really scalable.
And it's like, they always focus on sales and marketing, you know, and then they focus on,
I don't know why it's doing that. They focus on sales and marketing and then they focus on
operations and then the money's part always comes last. And so we like to inspire people like,
Hey, do it all right now. Like get the foundation laid so you can focus on those things and not
scaling your money doesn't become an interruption of your business growth, you know, later when you
are trying to, you know, when you are doing great numbers, now it's super costly to redo everything
later on. So, so anyway, that's kind of a background as well as like what I want to talk about with,
with your community today is like really laying that foundation properly.
Okay, bro. And yeah, what I said right before you hopped on is I heard somebody say this a couple
years ago, they said, you know, a lot of people that do side hustles, they get frustrated because
they're just making like a little bit of money. And it's like, if you want to make professional
money, you need to treat this professionally. And so a lot of times we get into this, we treat it
like with something we're doing out of our mom's basement. And even if you are literally in your
mom's basement, or something equivalent, you could still treat this like you're sitting at the, you
know, at Kale's office at a corner office, and then this really nice building. But this is one
of those things where you need to have your, your, your, what is it, your I's dotted your T's crossed.
And so fortunately, my dad was always, he told me this, he said, never be cheap on your accountant
or your attorney. And so even when I was barely making money, like when I first started doing
business, I always like I set up my first business, I had it done with a professional,
like I never was. He always put that in my head. He's always, you're the you know, are you going
to lose the most money is like, I'm like, where he's like doing the turbo tax and the QuickBooks.
And so I never even questioned it because he ingrained it. But I know that that's not how
everybody grew up. I know a lot of my friends grew up. It's like, Dad, you know, he was a school
teacher. And so he just went on the turbo tax and it was 200 bucks. Like, no, you just lost money
because you're an idiot. So anyway, that said, dude, I want to give you the floor to do some
training on what you want to talk about ways that people can save money in 2024. And then if there's
time left, I've got questions on other people got questions. But yeah, let's, let's get
I would definitely love to open up some q&a. And I know Casey will jump in here as well. Because
I mean, Casey's on the front lines all the time, man. He's always staying up to date on
cool deductions and tax strategies that are counted as the CPAs are, are, you know,
implementing for our clients. And so but but yeah, dude, to get to get kind of started. I mean,
that is that is one thing I want to start off by saying, I kind of iterated it there in the intro
was like, really, we want to we want to get to a point of like financial security and abundance
as quickly as possible. And we and we want to scale to that to that level as soon as possible.
And so obviously, one thing I've realized with entrepreneurs is, do they they don't ever just
want one stream of income, they want multiple streams of income. And so what happens is,
they they end up creating all these different buckets of income. And then they sometimes
end up partnering on things like, for example, your business model is a beautiful business model.
There might be opportunities in the marketplace that come up like, hey, maybe they're sending
you more business and they've created a new stream of income, or maybe they end up building
a team where they're out there helping a bunch of other people in their community do what you're
doing. And you know, I mean, so it's like, there's all these different streams of income entrepreneurs
do once they start making more and more money, like, how can I scale? How can I scale? And so
let me see if I can bring up this one slide, I want to kind of do a little training on
Let me give you co host, then you want to share your screen? Are you going to show it on that
screen over there? Let me see how it looks real quick on on just the laptop. Okay, cool,
because either way, I'm not used to the whiteboard thing, man. I'm like,
this is so interesting, you know, but I want to learn it.
It's all good, man. And I'm gonna do this. Hold on, let me see if I can give you like
spotlight so that it shows just your face alone. Yeah. Okay, it's spotlighting the whiteboard.
But I'm getting, I'm getting that like 1000 different tiles showing into eternity, you know,
let me try some here. Because I want to walk people through kind of a
current. Let's go to your slide. Yeah, I want to show people a current kind of how I'm personally
structured. And then kind of give them a good I want I want people to understand kind of now and
the future and why it's so beneficial for them to get all structured properly, you know, so
can you see that slide? Yeah, that's that's I can see it. Guys, let me know in the comments,
you can see it. I can see it pretty well. So I think I think it's pretty solid. Yeah.
Okay, so I'll walk you through some of this stuff. This is this is important stuff. I
really hit home, I've went and talked to some groups before. And you know, we spend a lot of
time on this, because, you know, really, the first understanding that we have to create as we are
starting a business is like, there's there's different kinds of income that the IRS looks
at, right? And one of them is, you know, active income, which is all your business activities,
and then business owners, they either want to go create multiple streams of income, because they
get good at business, or they want to start diversifying and building passive streams of
incomes, you know, which is buying assets and, you know, things that are taxed at capital gains
rates. And so we have to we have to have an understanding of like, what, what am I making?
What am I doing right now? It's like, okay, well, you're doing active income with your business
model, Nick, like this, what they're doing, they're doing active income. But as you if you want to
become scalable, you really want to create security, you know, one day, you're going to
have to start investing. Well, when you start buying stocks that you hold for over a year,
you start buying assets that you hold for over a year, like rental properties or whatever,
the appreciation on those gains is taxed at passive income. Well, we don't want that to pass
through to us as active income, you know, because then we're going to get taxed at earned income
rates, you know, which can be, you know, well, it can be 15% up to 37%, right? Plus your stake
taxes. And, you know, and then there's a lot of double taxation, we got to look out for on the
active income streams as well. Like right now, when you're not making any money, or you're just
starting to make a little bit, you don't obviously start paying taxes until you start becoming
profitable. Okay, once you become profitable, if you're just set up as a single member LLC,
or a sole proprietorship, which is just doing business in your name, you know, the income's
all passing through to you directly, and you're going to get taxed your earned income rates,
which is the 15 to 30%, plus your state taxes, if you're in a state where there's state taxes,
and then you're going to also pay the self-employment taxes. And the self-employment
taxes are basically the, the social security for both the employee and the employer. Well,
they're saying, well, hey, you're self-employed, it's all flowing through to you. So you need to
pay all of it. So it ends up being 15.3%. Right? So, and so, so people start doing the math,
and they're like, man, like, I'm paying 40, 45, 50% in taxes on this income that's flowing
through to me. Then they're like, I started this as a side hustle, so I could quit my job. They're
like, man, I'm never gonna be able to quit my job when I'm, you know, literally having to give
half of it back to the, to the government, you know? And so one of the biggest tax savings that
we can create for people is helping them understand where to start and when the right time is to
switch to an S corporation. Okay? But we don't want people to do it incorrectly. And so I built
this little diagram to give people kind of an idea. And, and this is a little outdated. Some of these
companies that have sold, like I'm not a part of RBO anymore. I've sold that. I sold you tax over
here. I am still owner of these other companies. And then, you know, I have some other things like
coffee shops now that me and my wife are doing it. So this is outdated. This isn't, this isn't my
exact situation anymore. I need to jump in and update it one of these days. But if you look at,
if you look at what we got going on right in the center, it says KG3 Corp. KG3 Corp is an S
corporation. All these other entities are either LLCs or LLC partnerships. Down here, my rental
properties at the bottom, those are all holding LLC companies. Okay? So some are flowing directly
through me. Some are flowing directly to my corporation, which is then where I pay myself.
And so a lot of people are asking question when they get started, like, do I even need to set up
an LLC? Right? And I always tell people like, absolutely do. Like there is no reason why you
shouldn't set up an LLC. An LLC doesn't really do a whole lot to save you money on taxes because
it's taxed just like a sole proprietorship is. Okay? But a sole proprietorship, the money flows
directly through you. Same with an LLC. And then there's also the S corporation. Okay? And so
the S corporation is taxed as a corporation. The benefit of that is you don't have to pay the 15.3%
self-employment taxes, but there's some rules. Like, first of all, you have to pay yourself a
fair and reasonable salary. And what the IRS says is they say it's fair and reasonable. That's all
they put in there. They don't give any stipulations or guidance on it. They say you just have to pay
yourself a fair and reasonable salary for your duties of the job. So somebody could be, let's just
give an example. Let's say you start this business and you decide, hey, I want to set up as an LLC.
And here's the benefit of setting up as an LLC. First of all, you get to create separation between
you and the business. Okay? So now we can establish a lot of really good habits, right? Like we can,
you know, separate the business transactions from the personal transactions. We go down to our bank,
we take our EIN, we set up the bank account numbers, totally separate from us. There's liability
protection. If anyone tries to sue the business, they can't sue me as long as I don't do any
commingling. If they try to sue me, they can't sue the business. So I've got separation between me
and the business. So there's all these benefits. I tell people, absolutely, you should always set
up an LLC. There's very rare situations that you should not set up an LLC, right? And so I always
tell people, LLC is great, okay? And they're usually super affordable. Some states, they have
high state fees, but most of the time they're super affordable. It's worth setting up just
to establish the right habits and the separation for the legalities, okay? But we're still being
taxed at earned income rates and we're still being taxed like a sole proprietorship. We're still
liable to pay those self-employment taxes, but that doesn't matter until we're profitable,
okay? Well, what pass-through means, Nick, is pass-through means the deduction, the income
flows through directly to you and that's where you get taxed, but then so do all the deductions.
So we like to teach people like, hey, set up an LLC, create as many tax deductions as possible.
We don't want to become super profitable until we absolutely start outweighing all of the
deductions that we possibly can. We want to pay as little as possible as far as taxes go.
Anyway, so we like to set up the LLC to start, okay? And then we like to educate people. When
is the right time to switch to an S corporation? Well, because an S corporation does have a little
bit higher cost tax return and it has some compliance, things like setting up some payroll
and there's a little payroll cost to pay yourself a fair and reasonable salary to get out of those
self-employment taxes. We like to tell people like, hey man, as soon as you start outweighing
all your deductions and you start getting to the point where you're making $20,000 a year profit,
it's really beneficial to start looking at switching to an S corporation. But there's a
lot of mistakes that happen along the way when people go to CPAs or attorneys to do this because
a lot of times CPAs and attorneys, they're just looking at it as a tax law. They'll tell you to
switch too soon or they'll tell you to switch too late because they're just looking at it from
a taxation point. And so they're not looking at it like from a business owner perspective.
And so a business owner perspective, we want to have sometimes multiple structures created to
create the best tax savings opportunity and get out of the self-employment taxes, maximize as many
deductions as we possibly can. So to break it down in kind of simple math, let's just say,
easy for math, you go start the side hustle, you're a couple of years in, boom, you're making
$100,000 a year profit. Well, you're probably going to end up paying about, on the profit,
just as an LLC, you're going to end up paying $35,000 to $45,000 after the self-employment taxes
directly to the IRS. And so that's a huge tax liability people don't want. But if you switch
at the right time to an S corporation, well, then you're eliminating the 15.3% right off the top.
And you've created the separation between you and the business to create a lot more different
tax strategies to reduce the taxation even more. And so I built this diagram just to break it down.
So I keep all of my partnerships and all of my single-member LLCs,
all, which are all the ones that have the arrows pointing to the KG3 Corp. I keep all those LLCs.
I don't switch any of them to S corporations. And then I flow them all to my S corporation,
which is there where I pay my, that's where I pay myself a fair and reasonable salary. And that's
where I end up taking most of my personal tax deductions that aren't tied to all my different
partners and all my different business ventures. And so this is the foundation we like to lay with
entrepreneurs early on so that they can gain an understanding of like,
okay, when is the right time to switch to an S corporation? How can I flow my money to me without
being double-taxed? And so this is the best way to do it, depending on your situation. Some people
are in different situations. We've had people come to us where they have disability or they have a
high-income earning spouse, or they have a partner that's overseas and so they need a S corporation.
So there's different situations for different people that we have to take into consideration
that we do consult on before we do anything. But this is like a good broad diagram that we built
just to help people kind of understand the benefits of LLCs, creating separation, maximizing deductions,
flowing it to you personally so you don't get double-taxed to keep majority of the money that
you're making as a business owner. So just to understand your setup is KG3 is an S Corp
and these other entities are LLCs that flow into KG3, but KG3 is what actually pays you.
Yeah, exactly. And I know I like to paint this future picture, Nick, just to give people
understanding of like, okay, like this seems like it could be a complex thing, but people are like,
where can I start now? Do I need an LLC right now? And so I like to paint this picture
for people because I don't want to see them make the mistakes that a lot of business owners make
later when they do get to the point where they're like, hey, I'm starting to become profitable,
and I have a partner and they go to talk to an accountant or a CPA and the CPA is like,
well, you're going to save 15.3% by switching to an S Corp. Well, now your partner and you have
an S Corp together, but now you guys have joined each other together on this corporation. When you
didn't have to do that, you could have kept your business in LLC and you could have just each set
up your own individual S corporations. And now you guys have the independence, right? So this
partner over here can go and build other multiple streams of income and assets that flow to him.
And you can go and build multiple streams of income separately, but you still have your thing
together in the LLC, but you each have your own individual S corporations. And then that's
where you kind of fully control your tax liability. And so that's like one of the biggest mistakes I
see for people as they scale and grow a business and create multiple streams of income is they end
up forming their S corporation when it's time to switch to an S corporation and they keep their
partner on it. And so that's a big thing I like to educate people on the future side of things.
But right now, while we're just getting started, I like people to understand the benefits of just
getting an LLC, maximizing as many deductions as possible to keep as much money as you possibly can
and then switch to an S corporation when the time is right based on you and then doing it properly
by keeping it S corporation solely under you and not tying yourself to any partners with that
down the road. So I like to paint that future picture, but then I like to help people
understand the benefits of setting up an LLC right now for the legalities and all the tax
incentives and the separation that they can create or the, you know, incentives that they
do create by creating that separation. So anyway, does that make sense so far?
Yeah, no, no, no. So, and I think it's smart because you guys, once you, you know, some of
you guys are brand new to business, first time ever. And you realize what, like, I'm sure you
were like this kale, but once you make money, then it's like the whole world's open and you're like,
oh, I can make money here. I can make money. And the hardest part is just not getting shiny
penny syndrome, to be honest, but you are going to find you're going to have multiple streams of
income. That's just inevitable. One of the questions I had, and I think you just nailed
it just to clarify. So your suggestion would be for anybody that's new, a good first step would
be set up an LLC slash start getting as many tax deductions as possible. That's like an amazing
first step. Totally, totally. And honestly too, like just having that entity set up properly,
because here's the thing, like you're going to go out and you're going to start establishing like,
okay, so I'm in digital landlords. I'm going out to find my first client. My first client,
he's like, Hey, I want to, I want to pay you on my, my MX every month for this deal. We've created
it. Well, now you need a merchant account and a merchant account doesn't want to, you know,
they don't, you know, like, you know how merchant accounts are Nick, they're pain in the ass,
you don't want to go set up a merchant account right now in your name. And then later be like,
Oh, I actually need a new merchant account because I want to set up an LLC because I figured out,
I have all this liability and I want all these tax incentives. And so then they're like, Oh,
cool. Now you need a whole new merchant account. Now you're trying to make a new, you know,
you're trying to make your, you're trying to season another merchant account, right? And you
have to kind of start over. And so, you know, that's just like one example of like, why not
just set up an LLC now if it's affordable for you, right? Cause like some States are 25 bucks,
right? It's like 25 bucks, state filing fees, set up an LLC. Now you have an EIN number. Now
you're protected legally. Now you can go start establishing bank accounts, merchant accounts,
contracts, agreements with your clients, like all these things under this company,
which is totally separate from you for the liability protection. And you can start taking
all your deductions, keeping your books totally separate from you. There is no, as long as you
really do a good job at setting up bank accounts and keeping those expenses separate, set up a
QuickBooks account or set up some spreadsheets. And now you're keeping everything separate from
you. And you're establishing really, really valuable habits early on in your business to not
only help you keep more, more money that you make, but, but really like, you know, like you're,
you're getting it all set up properly in the beginning stages. You don't have to redo it all
later. Cause if you set up your structure, you're flowing correctly. And then later you figure out,
you know what, I should, I should have been a C Corp or you know what I set up on as a C Corp
on accident. Now I need to go back and do this in LLC. Well, now you have to go redo all those
things. You have to get new merchant accounts, new agreements, new insurance policies, new bonds. If
you need bonds with your state, new like everything under this new entity, because everybody views an
entity as a totally separate entity. It's, it's not you anymore. And it's not this other company
anymore. So if you have to redo it, it's like, man, that causes a huge interruption in your
business. So starting with an LLC is very wise because one, if you're the sole owner of the
business and you decide to switch it to an S corporation later on, you can, or if you decide
to switch it to a C corporation later, you can, you know, and like, and that's, and that's necessary
at times as well. If you scale really massively and you'd be end up becoming, you know, creating
this business venture to something very large, you can switch to a C corporation and avoid paying
taxes on the first $10 million that you make in the sell of your business later on. But you have
to be a C corporation for five years. And so I tell you all that just because an LLC is very
versatile. Start now, create the habits, get the EINs, get everything set up properly. And then later,
if it makes sense, switch it to an S corp or set up a totally separate S corp if you have partners.
And then later, you know, if you, if you decide I'm gonna switch it to a C corp, because I want to
sell this business one day for 20, 30, 40, $50 million, well, you want to make that first 10 million
totally tax free, you know, so there's all these cool benefits that you can do from being an LLC
and switching later on or just adding entities like I've done for later on as well. So if I
ever sold, for example, easier accounting, I would, I would, I would just flow that to my,
my S corporation, or maybe by that time, hopefully I've switched to a C corporation,
you know, so there's just there's benefits that you can do to, to
just from starting as an LLC and keeping it very simple, and then understanding these things as you
grow. We have a question that is pertinent to what you just said. It said, Stephen says,
for those just starting out, do you recommend getting the LLC in the state you live in? He said,
Pennsylvania for me as an example, having Google or YouTube this once I get ads now for all sorts
of states, LLC is now algorithm. So yeah, should they do it in the state that they're in?
I want to, I want to save people a ton of money by not getting scammed. Okay.
When you get on the, when you get into business and you set up your first LLC,
you're going to start getting a lot of advertisements and stuff saying, Hey,
set up in Delaware, set up in Nevada. Okay. Now there's benefits to that. Okay. However,
they don't usually apply. Okay. The IRS is if you ever get audited, they are going to treat you
based on where your taxable presence is, you know, so if you're in Pennsylvania and you got sold by
somebody who says, Hey man, set up a Nevada corporation because now you don't pay state taxes.
That is a big audit waiting to happen that you will lose because they're going to be like,
do you have no taxable presence in Nevada? Why are you trying to say you're in Nevada?
You know, a business paying about a taxes plus as an LLC, it all flows to you directly anyway.
So I get probably, I don't know, a hundred people every year that are like, Oh man,
I set up in Nevada. I'm like, okay, cool. Why? And they're like, well, because I don't pay state
taxes. I'm like, well, that's not true. Okay. Or I talk to people in California that come just like,
Hey, I need some help fixing stuff and I need to set up in, in my, in California.
And they're, and I'm like, okay, why? Well, I set up in Nevada and I got audited.
California, they're like ninjas, man. They will find you. Cause if you put anyone on payroll
in Pennsylvania or even yourself on payroll in Pennsylvania, but your entities in Nevada,
there's like all these things that will trigger them to investigate that. Right. And so your
taxable presence is where you're at because you're the business. And then as the organization grows
and say, you remove yourself from the business and you, for example, wanted to move to Nevada
and become a resident of Nevada or Puerto Rico or Florida or wherever there's no freaking state
taxes. Well, then you can set up your S corporation as a consulting company, consulting your other
entities and flow money to you without paying state taxes. Right. But you got to go live there.
Right. Because now you're a consultant out of Florida, you're a consultant out of Nevada,
you know, and you're, those are the states that you're actually in where your taxable presence
is. And so I hate when people fall for that scam. Now there is anonymity. So in Delaware, Nevada,
Wyoming, there is anonymity saying, well, sorry, can you, sorry. Oh, yeah. Okay. Sorry. My screen
changed. Okay. And so I just have you on this conversation. Oh, just me and you. No, everyone
can see you, but I just changed. You're the spotlight and I'll change it back when you're
done talking. Okay. Okay. So basically, and so basically to save you a ton of money,
I always tell people, like, dude, just set up in your state. That's going to save you a ton of
money. Not it's going to, you know, avoid a ton of headaches later down the road. There are very
cool strategies later that you can create by setting up entities in other states, but the whole
anonymity laws are great because, you know, like it shields you. Like if somebody was going to sue
you, like, let's just say you had a crazy ex wife. It's like, I know he's got like all these assets
he's bought with this new business. He started in digital landlords. And like, let's say you wanted
to hide a piece of land from a crazy ex spouse or, you know, or an ex business partner that's always
trying to sue you or whatever, right? Like you could go set that up as just a holding LLC that
owns land in Delaware or owns land or Wyoming or Delaware LLC that owns land in these other states,
but it's just shielding you from them, but you got to set them up properly. And so most people,
even when they set up a Nevada or Delaware corporation, they don't even set them up properly.
They end up setting them up and then they list themselves as an officer. So now they're public
information anyway, you know, so you have to actually go set, like hire an attorney to set
up the entity act as the officers of the corporation or the entity to totally shield you from the entity
and then all of your ownership is basically created in agreements with that attorney or
that law firm in order to fully shield it from you. So when you get to the point of where you're
really wealthy and you're starting to set up trusts and land trusts, and you want to hide assets and
really keep your name off of them, then you talk about like Nevada, Delaware, Wyoming entities,
but when you're just starting a business, there's a money trail always leading back to you. Anyway,
there's no, there's no point in you setting up out of state. So I know that gets a little bit long,
but there is, you know, a lot of that I want to help people avoid by not getting scammed because
I know there's companies out of Nevada and stuff that will call and sell you Nevada corporation
and they'll charge you five, six, $7,000 for this corporate package, making it sound like you're
never going to pay state taxes and you're going to have all these privacy laws and then they don't
even set them up properly for the privacy laws. And so typically 99% of the time you don't want
to set up out of your own state. Makes sense. Okay. So here's what I want to do really quick
in our last few minutes. Because I know some people might hop off right at the,
at the hour mark, whatever, but I have a couple of questions that people did ask that I think
are really interesting that we should answer. But if like, I would suggest guys, this is what I did
when I first got started is like, you got to talk to somebody, figure out what your situation is,
what the best, you know, like way forward is whatever. So what's the best way that somebody
didn't want to reach out and like, for example, we had a question just barely asking about a
specific situation. How can people get in contact with you if they want to call and just kind of
talk through their situation? Yeah, we put together a link just for digital landlords. I'm gonna have
case and pull this up. So you guys can scan a QR code for it right now off the other screen.
If you want to highlight that one, Nick, but that's just, it's really just a QR link going to
link that we built just for the digital landlords community. That way it's tagged to your community
where we give you guys a full, a free tax assessment, because I know we're getting in,
we're in the fourth quarter of the year, first of all. So if you guys jump on the phone with our
team, you know, we're not going to talk about just LLCs and everything. We're going to actually talk
about you guys, your goals. We're going to talk a little bit about the future stuff, but we're
going to talk about all the things you can do right now this year to start saving money because you
started this business in this year, which means we can take a ton of deductions this year for your
home office, for your vehicle, for your business bills, for your travel, for your laptop, your
cell phone, your cell phone bills, your utilities, like all these things that you spend money on
personally every year anyway. We want to show you guys how you can deduct those and pass it through
to you. Whether you're an LLC, whether you're a sole proprietorship, whether you're a corporation,
we want to help create an assessment for you guys where we can help you understand like, wow,
this business is really benefiting me this year because when people go spend money to start a
business, dude, they're like, holy crap, like it takes a little time before I start making a little
bit of money. How can I get more money to put back into the business or how can I put more money back
in my pocket to recoup costs? Well, when you set up an LLC and you strategize, all these deductions
pass through to you directly anyway, so we offer this free assessment where people can literally,
we can get on our phone with our team, we can look at your lifestyle, a broad estimate of all
your expenses that we can now make deductible, show you how we're going to pass them through,
and literally give you kind of a broad range of like, dude, we could save you this much money this
year and an extra tax refund money from starting this business, right? So we can show people in
this assessment how much money they can really save. Can I jump in real quick and say, we typically
charge $400 for this assessment. We're doing it for free just for digital landlords. So like,
if you're on this call right now, seriously, I can't tell you how many times I've been in an event and
pulled up the QR code and thought, I need to go talk to my business partners. So I just open up
the window thinking of it back to it when I get back in town and coordinate with my business
partners. Don't do that. Click on this QR code right now. If you've got friends, family members,
or business partners that are involved with you, just put your information in. My team will reach
out. That way it's not an afterthought or something else you forget about. Now, another thing, I have
not made this free offer since January. And the reason for that is last time I did this,
people screenshot it, which is great. But there was 150 people at the event and we had 300
scheduled appointments. And so it got a little bit crazy. So again, this is for you, your friends,
family members, and business partners that are involved. But my team knows digital landlords
very well. They understand your business. But again, we need to get on and really assess what
your specific situation is and what your goals are to point you in the next right direction.
And I promise you, you're going to leave this call with better information when you got on this call.
So we're excited to work with you and appreciate everybody's time today.
Yeah. One thing I want to say on that is I know for me, when I was looking to get a new attorney
to potentially set up my trust, I reached out and I think it was like $250 or $300 an hour.
And so I did pay that just to do an initial consultation. So what these guys are offering
is like, hey, get on a call, let's look at your situation, see where you can save some money,
see if you should set up an LLC. And anyway, I would just recommend if you guys want to make
professional money, as I said in the beginning, you got to treat this professionally. So this is
just a free thing that you guys can check out and then you can just go from there. And they
just literally just scan that with their phone and then they can put in their information.
I think I actually shared the link with you in our chat, Nick, if you want to share it in the
comments or something, because I don't know if I have that ability, right? And if you want,
we can give you the link, you can email us all of them or however you want to do it. But yeah,
the QR code is in the same place. It's just for us to grab the information so we can reach out
and just get you on the calendar. And then at the end of the day, man, it's like, yeah, we love
earning business. We love helping people and going ahead and doing the structures for them. We do it
all very affordably. But at the end of the day, we really want to provide enough value to where
if somebody even can't hire us right now, it's like, we still want to head you in the right
direction, give you direction this year to save as much money as possible so that maybe one day
down the road, you want to come back and consult with us a little bit more. And so it's not a high
pressure thing is all I'm saying. It's an awesome consultation, customized around you, your goals
for the business and show you how we can to show you how we can help you save money now
and down the road. So so I just barely dropped a link on the in the comments and I'll try to
include the link as well. I'll edit the live and post it there. But yeah, we'll try to like email
this out. Let me just see one more thing. Let's just answer two questions quick and then pop off
you can. Is that okay, Kale? And as you want, man, we'll answer any questions you have.
Okay, so real quick, Nick, Nick, I'm gonna ask this one because he's actually in St. George.
He went to Utah Tech and stuff. And he said, random question, is your firm well versed in handling
1031 exchanges? I'm seeking a reputable local firm to assist me in the process.
Yep, we can do 1031s. We do cost tags, real estates, one of one of the fields that we do,
we do a lot of work in and very, very well. Yeah, most of our most of our clients are
e commerce or real estate, you know, and so, yeah, we're pretty well versed in all of that. So
made absolutely. Okay, another one quick says, I set up my own LLC in Nevada and filed. This is
more just a comment. Nevermind. This is just stating something. What this is a question
that says from Juan says, What about creating a trust and having all the LLC inside the trust?
And it sounded like based on what you were saying is that's like when you get into the big money,
it's not necessarily right off the bat. But what do you want to talk about?
Very, very careful, because there's a lot of different ways that trust or structure,
there's a lot of different ways that the trust can own that business. And if it's done wrong,
you're going to wind up paying trust taxes, which is the absolute highest tax rate that there is.
And so that's one thing where great idea to be to be thinking at that higher level.
But do not like, please do not do that without a lot of consultation with a tax professional
and an attorney. Okay, I hope that answered. Let's see, Matt Torres said, he said, so starting
the business as an LLC first, then later converting to an S corp or forming an S corp separately is a
better strategy rather than leaving it as an LLC for the long run?
Well, I mean, it depends. Like, so for example, if you do have a business partner, or, you know,
like, let's just say you're a personal trainer, and you're an LLC, and then you meet somebody,
and they're like, Hey, we should build gym equipment together. And you know,
now you have a partnership and, you know, like, it's, it's, it's best to leave them all in LLCs
when you start involving other people. And then just forming a totally separate S corporation
that you now are flowing the money to. So for example, if me and Nick are in business together,
and we go create an entity together, but we have all these other things, it's, it's not wise for us
to go switch it to an S corp. Once it becomes profitable, it's wise for us to actually just set
up our own S corporations. And instead of flowing the money directly to us, now we float to our S
corporation, which is then where we pay ourselves. However, staying in LLC long term, that's totally
fine. Until if you're even if you're a single member, until you start making 30, 40, $50,000
a year and up, if then it's wise to switch it to an S corporation, right. And so, but
if you know, you're just entrepreneurial, and you know, I'm going to go start other companies,
I tell people it's best to just leave it in an LLC and go form a separate S corporation,
and start doing that flow right now. Because you already know, you're going to go create these
other LLCs, and you'd rather them all just flow to this S corporation. So, so it really just depends
on your goals and the situations. If you know, like, I'm not going to do anything else, this is
it, you know, then let's just switch that LLC to an S corp. You know, no, and you don't have
any partners in it. No sweat. You're like, hey, I know, I just want to make 15, 20 grand a month,
I'm good with that. You know, I just, you know, I don't want to have partners, I don't want it,
I just want to keep it super simple. Well, then we can switch it to an LLC, LLC, to an S corp,
and you get the same tax savings, you know. And so, so it really just depends on you, your situation.
But I hope that answers the question. It just there is somebody. Yeah, I think it just I think
if anyone has questions that specific like that, just jump on and talk to case and talk to kale,
they'll answer it for your situation. So it's pretty simple. The other thing, this is a side
note that I never realized is like, down the road, if you guys want to, you know, buy real estate
with your company or whatever qualify for certain things, when if you're LLC, or your business is
like brand new, I mean, it's really, really difficult. So you want to get it set up now,
get it seasoned, get however many years of tax returns, because they're going to look at a brand
new business. And basically, you know, they're, they're not even going to consider it. So
that's another thing that you you have to you don't even think about these things until you
get in a situation, you're like, man, I wish I would have set that up five years ago.
Yeah, I always tell people when you set up an LLC, and this is another whole benefit of why you
should set them up early on, instead of waiting, is because you can you go get a DUNS number,
you start building credit to your corporation. And like, you know, and there's a lot of misleading
information out there, like, oh, yeah, once you set up, you know, you get corporate credit, you can
just transfer all the debts to the you know, off you to the business, and you're not liable to pay
them anymore. And it's like, that stuff's not true. There's, there's always like, a way it's
going to come back on you if you try and like, just walk away from a debt or something. But
there is a ton of benefits to corporate lines of credit, even if you are a personal guarantor,
there's loans you can get just through the company where you're not a signer on them.
And so and sometimes it takes a good couple years to really season an entity before
banks or institutions will give you money through the corporation. So anyway, that's another benefit
of starting to set up an LLC now is you can open up more lines of credit and access to capital
through that entity by starting to establish some credit through it. Beautiful. I'll say this guys,
and what I'll try to do, Kay, I'll try to get an email put together and send it out to everyone
that missed this. But the thing that I like about these guys, for everyone that's watching this is
that, you know, a lot of times you deal with accountants, or you deal with these type of
firms, it's just like that, that old guy that's friends with your dad. And you guys are actually
business owners that understand business and accounting. And so I think that's important,
because I've had you know, I had an accountant for a while when I got started, he used to do my dad
stuff on the farm and everything. And he was good, but you had to tell him, hey, what about this?
What about this? What about this? He was an accountant, he was just like one of those purists,
he didn't really know business, if I don't even think he was making that much money, although he
knew the accounting, he wasn't a business owner. So that's one benefit with these guys is they're
actually business owners that happen to know accounting very well. So anyway, we're going to
put together an email, I did drop the link. And we will, yeah, guys, just jump on, check out what
they can do. If anything, suggestions, if nothing else, you guys get some ideas and go from there.
Yeah, no, we appreciate it, man.
Beautiful. I'm sure we'll come. I'm sure we'll do another one, where we can just like maybe we can
gather a bunch of questions and just have like, I bet we could spend an hour just on q&a, which
could be a cool part to this. So I'll message you guys will chat and see. This has been really
beneficial. And I actually learned quite a bit. And I've been trying to piece this stuff together
for years. So appreciate you guys.
Well, it was a zoom call. So I was like, trying to bounce around.
It was good. You know, for sure. Well, don't appreciate you encasing up and on. And yeah,
guys, you feel that out. They'll reach out schedule a call and see, you know, what you guys some
of the next steps you guys can take if you choose to do so. So awesome. Thanks, guys.